Traduttore: David Mammano
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Chi lo sa se parlerò
della bellezza, forse no.
Vi racconterò una storia:
c'era una volta un paese meraviglioso,
il più bel Paese del mondo.
Quel paese c'è ancora,
naturalmente, ed è il nostro:
tutto contornato dalle Alpi,
con delle pianure stupende sotto le Alpi,
e poi cominciano le colline,
e poi cominciano gli Appennini,
e poi si arriva in fondo,
con quel triangolo fantastico.
E in questo paese,
che tutti hanno sempre voluto,
dai Celti, Annibale,
tutti hanno voluto l'Italia!
Va bene, in questo paese naturalmente
abitavano tante persone,
abitavano dai tempi antichi,
però una volta
il paese era pericoloso
e quindi la gente abitava
in poche città e in tanti paesi,
ma queste città e questi paesi
erano tutti contornati da mura
perché fuori era pericoloso,
fuori c'erano i boschi,
c'erano i lupi, c'erano i briganti!
Per cui la gente si raccoglieva intorno
e viveva in questi piccoli paesi,
costruiva delle mura che li difendessero!
Certo, le mura non potevano essere enormi
perché costruire delle mura
costava un sacco di soldi,
mantenerle anche, poi presidiarle pure!
E quindi all'interno i paesi
erano abbastanza piccoli
e le strade erano strette
fra una casa e l'altra,
le case avevano poca aria
perché non c'era tanto spazio.
Però c'erano anche
delle belle piazze, all'interno,
perché non erano mica formicai!
E sulle piazze dava la Chiesa,
nelle piazze ci si trovava,
la piazza era un po’ l’agorà, no?
Era un po' come [il luogo]
dove i greci si trovavano a chiacchierare.
E poi c'era la chiesa, ripeto,
c’erano le grandi processioni!
Oggi i preti non ci sono più,
ma una volta ce n’erano un sacco di preti!
E quindi uscivano con i baldacchini
e poi tutti i chierichetti,
e anche quelli che magari non ci
credevano tanto andavano anche loro,
anche i briganti andavano
- che poi si erano stufati di vivere fuori
e sono andati a vivere anche loro
nei paesi, nei palazzi,
oggi vivono nei palazzi più importanti…
Ma fatto sta…
Insomma: questo paese meraviglioso
fu quello che poi nel 1338
Ambrogio Lorenzetti dipinse sulle mura
del Palazzo Pubblico di Siena:
quella città meravigliosa, chiusa
con tutte le porte, perché poi la mattina
si aprivano le porte e la gente
andava in queste campagne stupende,
coltivava le viti, le messi,
era una vita straordinaria!
Il paesaggio: l'uomo ha formato
il paesaggio con le sue mani!
Il paesaggio italiano,
oggi noi ne abbiamo perso un bel po',
ma ce n'è ancora tanto
di questo paesaggio stupendo.
E poi però quando veniva buio,
appunto, i lupi, i briganti,
tutti tornavano nei loro paesi,
si chiudevano le porte
e si stava bene all'interno
di questi paesi, di queste città;
si stava sicuri e ci si conosceva tutti,
perché si viveva in poco spazio;
e poi si aprivano le osterie,
si aprivano le bettole,
si aprivano anche le case chiuse,
una volta c'erano adesso non ci sono più.
Insomma,
era una vita che Ambrogio Lorenzetti
dipinse come “Il buon governo”.
Poi vennero i signori, vennero gli Este,
vennero i Medici, e vennero i Farnese,
quindi forse c’era un po' più
di sicurezza, probabilmente,
di lupi, a un certo punto
non ce n’erano più,
perché non c'era neanche il WWF,
ancora che li proteggeva,
per cui, evidentemente,
non c'era più nemmeno bisogno
di chiudere le porte la sera.
E poi quando c'erano le grandi guerre,
le bombe cadevano dal cielo,
quindi non c'era più
nemmeno bisogno delle mura.
E quindi a un certo punto si cominciò
ad andare a vivere fuori dalle mura:
e una casetta qui, una casetta lì,
poi a un certo punto
c’era un gran baccano!
E il fabbro faceva un casino d’inferno!
E il falegname faceva un sacco di polvere!
Quindi era meglio che
andassero fuori dalle mura,
tanto i pericoli
erano uguali dentro e fuori.
E poi dopo, per fortuna,
arrivarono anche i re,
arrivarono i Savoia,
e c’era anche il Papato
che faceva tutto quello -
non faceva quello
che diceva Papa Francesco:
faceva ben altro il papato a suo tempo.
E, insomma, fatto sta che però
le condizioni di vita
migliorarono anche, obiettivamente:
gli italiani diventarono più ricchi
e quindi cominciarono
quelle piccole fabbrichette,
il fabbro e falegname
s’ingrandirono, fuori delle mura,
e le città diventarono, quindi -
nelle città ci fu bisogno di più spazio
e quindi le strade strette delle città
diventarono dei grandi viali,
dei grandi viali alberati meravigliosi,
si costruirono giardini pubblici
stupendi, grandi
come il Parco Sempione di Milano,
come la Villa Comunale di Napoli!
E poi delle grandi piazze con i monumenti
ai principi, ai re, alle regine,
a tutti quelli più importanti del mondo!
Era molto bello vivere nelle città,
e nei paesi obiettivamente
c’erano un po’ meno soldi,
per cui di grandi viali alberati
non ce n’erano mica poi tanti.
E quindi cosa successe nei paesi?
Successe che la gente appunto cominciò,
siccome non c’era tanto spazio, a uscire.
E quindi… e poi ecco arrivarono
anche le grandi fabbriche, naturalmente,
quindi arrivò la fabbrica
che costruiva tante macchine,
arrivò la fabbrica
che costruiva tante gomme,
e quindi costruivano delle grandi case
per tutti gli operai,
che venivano anche dal sud
per far andare avanti queste fabbriche;
però la gente cominciò,
come dicevo prima, a stare meglio:
nelle case c'erano i bagni,
la scuola divenne obbligatoria,
nacquero i sindacati, gli ospedali.
La società, obiettivamente, insomma,
tutti noi viviamo meglio
di come si viveva nel Medioevo,
su questo non ci piove.
Però, certamente, cos'è successo?
Certamente è successo che tutti i paesi
tutti i 1000 paesi
- sono 7000, in Italia -
forse non tutti,
ma la stragrande maggioranza,
cominciarono a perdere significato
perché i figli di chi stava nei paesi
erano abbastanza ricchi,
quindi cominciarono
a fare un po' di soldi,
e quindi costruirono
un figlio una villetta,
un altro figlio un'altra,
la figlia invece andò ad abitare
col figlio di un'altra famiglia
che stava costruendo una villetta.
I nonni continuavano a vivere
nel paese, anche i genitori,
ma quando morirono i nonni
e quando morirono i genitori
quelle case in paese
non le voleva più nessuno,
perché le nuove case
avevano il garage per la macchina,
avevano un piccolo giardino,
magari anche una piccola
piscinetta, chi lo sa,
e quindi, insomma,
obiettivamente era più gradevole.
E poi, una volta i negozi
erano tutti nei paesi,
però una volta si andava
a piedi o in bicicletta,
ma perché andare a piedi o in bicicletta
che adesso ci sono le macchine?
Però una volta c’era la 600,
poi venne la 1100, poi venne la Peugeot,
poi vengono i SUV, perché oggi
tutti devono avere i SUV,
e quindi non c’è mica posto nei paesi
per andare a fare la spesa col SUV!
E quindi i negozi si trasferirono
fuori, là, vicino alle case,
dove ci sono le strade
provinciali, più grandi.
E quindi, la farmacia, il macellaio,
la cartoleria, la merceria chiusero tutti
e quindi nessuno aveva più
nessun bisogno di andare in paese,
perché era tutto fuori.
Per fortuna in paese c'era la Chiesa,
perché costruire delle chiese così belle
come quelle che c'erano una volta
costa un sacco di soldi!
Eh quindi, però, in chiesa
la gente ci va mica tanto oggi,
sì, ci va per la comunione,
non si sposa più nessuno
- se non altro al Nord -
per fortuna ci sono i funerali!
Per cui ai funerali
tutti vanno nelle chiese,
almeno ogni tanto si va in centro!
Però fatto sta
che i centri dei nostri paesi,
mentre le città si sono adeguate,
i centri dei paesi sono morti.
I centri dei nostri paesi sono diventati
- parliamo del Varesotto,
ma anche del Veneto -
sono diventati in un certo senso
le periferie dei nuovi paesi
che sono andati all'esterno.
E allora la storia che vi racconto oggi,
negli altri 5 minuti che ho,
è la storia di Morazzone.
Forse voi conoscete tutti
il paese di Morazzone,
uno dei tanti paesi del Varesotto,
è un bel paesotto,
ma non è Castiglione Olona:
un bel paesotto, ma neanche tanto bello.
Però ci sono tutte le sue vecchie case,
non c'è niente di speciale,
c'è un bel campanile,
ci sono due belle ville signorili,
però in quelle ci vivono solo i signori,
c'è una bellissima chiesa,
si vede lì nell'angolo,
costruita, a sinistra, da Simone Cantoni,
un grande architetto
tardo neoclassico lombardo.
In questo paese,
in quella casa che vedete lì,
viveva una signorina piuttosto bizzarra,
la quale, quando morirono
i suoi genitori, negli anni ’50,
chiuse casa e non entrò
mai più nella sua casa;
andava in giardino,
ma in casa non è più andata.
Si vede che aveva qualche
ricordo non felicissimo...
Fatto sta che questa casa è rimasta
una specie di Pompei dell’‘800,
perché era ancora arredata,
e tuttora lo è,
con i mobili scelti dai nonni
e poi conservati dai genitori,
dove tutto è rimasto come quando i nonni
di questa signorina l’arredarono.
Tutte le stanze, i letti,
le lenzuola, le tovaglie,
tutto piegato come una volta;
gli armadi pieni di cose,
le vetrine piene dei bicchieri
del rosolio, dello champagne,
tutti i servizi di piatti,
tutte le pentole,
le televisioni a schermo
piatto profonde così...
Un miracolo!
Io non ho mai visto in vita mia
una casa talmente ben conservata.
Allora la signorina, morendo,
la lascia al FAI, in eredità,
pregando il FAI di fare in modo di
raccontare ai morazzonesi la loro storia.
Allora, noi siamo abituati, di solito,
a gestire grandi ville
come Villa Panza, Villa Bozzolo,
dei pezzi d'Italia, di coste ecc.,
però l'idea di gestire una sorta
di racconto borghese normale,
come tanti ce ne sono stati,
che è quello, come dire,
dove hanno vissuto le persone
che hanno fatto l'Italia
- perché naturalmente
il nonno era garibaldino,
e poi il bisnonno era cacciatore -
Vabbe', fatto sta, cosa faccio?
Vado dal sindaco.
E ci sono questi giovani nuovi sindaci
che hanno capito
che la morte dei centri storici
dei nostri paesi è un dramma.
E quindi insieme abbiamo detto:
io accetto l'eredità,
però se tu mi dai una mano:
cioè se il progetto è quello di riportare
il rossore sulle gote di Morazzone,
perché a Morazzone non c'è più un negozio
tranne quello che si vede qui:
quella cartolibreria edicola
e poi c'è un ristorantino.
Ma noi, restaurando la casa
e riportandola
al suo originario splendore,
che poi è quello lì,
non bisogna toccare niente,
bisogna solamente togliere
queste ragnatele gigantesche
che sembrano tessute nei cotonifici
di Busto Arsizio dell'Ottocento
- è una cosa da pazzi,
perché nessuno è mai più entrato
per 80 anni, in quella casa!
E anche un giardino incantevole
con le palme, la peschiera,
la voliera: un sogno!
Allora la gente, forse, di Morazzone,
tornerà in centro a vedere e dirà:
[In dialetto] Ah, mi ricordo!
La mia nonna l’aveva così
anche lei! È uguale!”
Non parlo inglese, ma un pochino
di dialetto va bene, pazienza (Risate)
Questo forse darà ai morazzonesi
il motivo di ricordare che è anche loro;
ma poi noi porteremo anche 20, 25,
30 mila visitatori l'anno a Morazzone,
che dovranno girare per il paese!
Allora il ristorante farà più coperti,
e allora il cartolaio,
magari, venderà più quaderni!
E poi, ecco, e poi apriranno
forse nuovi negozi,
apriranno dei negozi di artigiani
e lì fanno del buon vino
e quindi venderanno il vino.
Cioè il centro storico, forse, tornerà!
Allora, perché dobbiamo tornare a credere
nei centri storici dei nostri paesi,
e dobbiamo evitare questa tristezza
che sono diventati
le periferie di loro stessi?
Eh, perché nel centro storico
c'è la nostra memoria:
sono nati i genitori, sono nati i nonni,
sono nati i bisnonni:
ci sono le storie che uniscono
i cittadini di Morazzone,
i cittadini di Azzate,
i cittadini di Caronno Pertusella,
i cittadini di Gavirate.
Uno è un buon cittadino del mondo
se è un buon cittadino d'Europa,
se è un buon cittadino d'Italia,
ma se è un buon cittadino del suo paese!
Se è forte delle sue tradizioni,
se è forte dei suoi ricordi!
Se sa anche intessere,
come ha detto Papa Francesco,
delle relazioni che oggi, purtroppo,
in quella “marmellata” di paesi
non si hanno più!
Una volta tutti si conoscevano in paese!
Se un bambino andava
dal cartolaio diceva,
- Ho bisogno di un quaderno,
poi passa la mamma.
- Ma certo, Roberto!
E poi si giocava in piazza,
- Roberto, a dormire!
- No perché Giovanni sta ancora
alzato un quarto d'ora! - Va bene!
Si parlava tutto così,
era una relazione fatta
di voci, di volti,
non era una relazione via web.
Ecco, io penso
che se noi torniamo a credere
nei centri storici dei nostri paesi,
torniamo a credere in noi stessi:
siamo più forti,
ci abituiamo a ricreare quelle relazioni
che ci aiuteranno a essere
dei cittadini più consapevoli
perché forti della storia
non soltanto dell'Italia,
non soltanto della Lombardia o del Veneto
ma forti della piccola,
fondamentale storia
del paese nel quale siamo nati.
(Applausi)